J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: Well, from
the happy hubbub, I gather
you're as eager as I am
to get this over.
So the last lecture is a review
of what we've done
before, actually.
But it's focused on synthetic
chemistry.
In particular, the synthesis
of cortisone, which is a
natural product.
Cortisone looks like this.
It's one of these steroids
which, remember, have three
six-membered rings, then a
five-membered ring, and
various alcohols and
ketones and so on.
And in fact, this lecture
originated with a book called
Advanced Organic Chemistry,
although I've used it so much
that you can't tell it from the
spine anymore, that was
written in 1961 when I was
taking organic chemistry by
Louis Fieser at Harvard, who was
the person I was having at
that time for this course.
He was a very good synthetic
organic chemist, and he worked
a lot on steroids.
In fact, in 1936, he wrote this
book, which is called
Chemistry of Natural Products
Related to Phenanthrene.
Phenanthrene three is a thing
like three benzene rings.
Bing, bing, bing.
So you see, steroids are related
to phenanthrene, so
that's what this
book was about.
He also was a stylish guy.
Before I got there, it was
reported that he walked around
with a gold headed cane.
He had dropped that affectation
by the time I arrived.
But he's still smoked like a
chimney, although at that
time, he was on the Surgeon
General's committee about
smoking and health, and he
absolutely quit then, and but
he ultimately succumbed
to lung cancer.
So this is a way of
homage to him.
These are some of the steroids,
the ones that are
sex hormones.
So very small amounts of them
go around and make various
things happen in your body.
And they begin up at the top
left with cholesterol, and you
can see how various enzymes
oxidize and put a ketone here,
an alcohol here, making
unsaturation and so on to make
all these important compounds.
In fact, they were recognized
as so important that work on
steroids awarded four Nobel
Prizes between 1927 and 1950,
and another three between 1965
and 1975, which were, at least
in part, due to work
on steroids.
The awards in 1927 and '28
were determining the
structure, and the one in
1965 recognized the
synthesis of it.
You have to know the structure
before you can
synthesize it, obviously.
In fact, the ones in 1927 and
'28 were for determining the
wrong structure.
The thing they got the Nobel
Prize for was this structure,
which doesn't have three
six-membered rings, bing,
bing, bing, like that.
But it got settled
in the 1930s.
So by 1950, the Nobel Prize in
Physiology or Medicine was
awarded to Kendall, Reichsten,
and Showalter Hench "for their
discoveries relating to the
hormones of the adrenal
cortex, their structure and
biological effects." So
Kendall and Reichstein were
organic chemists, and
Showalter Hench was a
physiologist.
And Hench's Nobel address
said "This air of pessimism
regarding the rheumatic disease
in general and rheumatoid
arthritis in particular still
finds expression in some of
the modern writings
and texts."
But then he goes on to describe
how he had a patient
at the Mayo Clinic, a
65 year old patient,
with an unusual story.
A few days before he came, he
was "painfully affected with
rheumatoid arthritis, and
had been for four years.
Then jaundice suddenly
developed, and within a week,
most of his arthritic
manifestations had
disappeared.
The jaundice lasted five weeks,
and the rheumatic arthritis
did not relapse until several
weeks after the jaundice had
disappeared.
"The thought occurred instead
of being relentlessly
progressive, this disease,
rheumatoid arthritis, may be
potentially reversible, more
so than we believed.
Perhaps rapidly so."
"So during the next five years,
from '29 to '34, while
the organic chemists were
determining the true
structure, observations were
made on sixteen patients with
chronic arthritis or fibrositis,
in whom jaundice
of different types and
degrees developed.
If the jaundice was deep
enough, it was characterized
by bilirubinemia of the
'direct-reacting' type, the
rheumatic symptoms quickly
diminished or disappeared for
varying lengths of time...
and then gradually returned."
And furthermore, it was
noted that during
pregnancy, people lost that.
So there was thought
to be some hormone
that would do this.
So they figured that out.
You can read that yourself.
OK.
So Reichstein then, the Swiss
chemist, took 1000 kilograms
of adrenal glands from cattle,
and was able to get a 1
kilogram of dry residue from
that and follow the activity
as he parcelled it out,
including using Girard's
ketone reagent T.
Remember, we talked about that's
the thing that makes a
hydrazone, and that it has a
permanent cationic charge, so
it will take a ketone into
water, then you can take it
off and it'll go back
into the organics?
That was a powerful way of
separating these ketones.
And so there we go.
So they got 7 to 8 grams of
a ketone out of that.
So this was this fishhook
to extract ketones.
We've talked about that before,
so I'm just going to
click through it very rapidly
to show how it was
synthesized.
And now we know what it did.
"Only when pure crystalline
homogeneous substances were
produced were they tested as far
as possible biologically.
So accurate determination
of chemical
structure was given priority.
In nearly all cases, this could
be elucidated in all its
details."
So now by the mid-1930s, they
had what the structures were.
And here were some of these
steroids from the adrenal
cortex, 29 of them, of which
these five were particularly
important as active.
Now those two, you notice,
are on the top cortisol.
It has an OH group on
the top left here.
And below it is cortisone,
the ketone.
So that position 11 and the
position 17 were particularly
important then.
You have to have that ketone
at 11 to get cortisone.
"The introduction of an oxygen
atom in position 11 of the
steroid skeleton is one of the
major difficulties in the
synthetic
production cortisone." Why?
Because it's so far away from
any other functional group.
It's not alpha to something, or
the beta position, where an
alpha beta unsaturation
could be used.
Right?
"The preparation of the
substance from deoxycholic
acid still remains a long and
laborious way, even when so
many improvements to it
have been discovered.
If it is wished to obtain
cortisone more simply, there
remain two ways.
Either total synthesis or the
discovery of a better
qualified raw material that's
close in structure to this,
that then you could
convert into
this for medical purposes.
Both will be tried.
The prospects of a total
synthesis are difficult to
assess."
So it's going to be
tough to do this.
Either total synthesis
or you've got find
a better raw material.
And there's a footnote there.
"R.B. Woodward referred to the
partial synthesis of an acid
which is already very closely
related to cortisone...
9 April 1951 in Boston, Mass."
And it gives a reference here.
OK.
So this book that I talked about
uses as an example of a
total synthesis Woodward's
synthesis in 1951 of cortisone.
And this is it, but we're going
to go through it slowly.
So this is the thing
he wanted to make.
It's got these four rings, A,
B, C, and D. And obviously
it's going to take a lot
of steps to get there.
So the first goal is to make
rings C and D. Why did I put a
question mark on D?
STUDENT: It's a
six-membered ring
PROFESSOR: It's a
six-membered ring, not a
five-membered ring.
So he's got something clever in
the back of his mind when
he thinks of that as the first
thing he wants to make.
And that will be a handle, that
double bond on the far
right, a handle to allow
modification, to make the ring
a smaller size and put
the functionality
that you need on there.
OK.
And this double bond at the
top left of ring C is the
thing that's going to allow us
to get access to put the
ketone on there.
And down at the bottom, this
ketone is a handle.
It's at this position
down here.
This is going to be a handle to
build the rings A and B. So
we'll see how that works.
So this compound was known and
readily available and cheap.
So you could get a lot
of it to start with.
So the first reaction he did was
to build ring D onto that.
How did he do that?
What kind of reaction could
build ring D, make these bonds
that are highlighted
in blue, here?
Anybody got an idea?
STUDENT: The Diels-Alder
reaction.
PROFESSOR: The
Diels-Alder reaction, Right?
So he did that, the standard old
Diels-Alder reaction, and
he put that ring on.
But notice when the diene sits
down on top of that double
bond, the methyl and the
hydrogen are going to be on
the same side.
Whereas over here, they want
to be on opposite sides.
So we better get that fixed up
so that they won't have the
wrong stereoisomer when
we get to the end.
Can you see any way to change it
so that this hydrogen is no
longer pointing down,
but pointing up?
Yeah, Amy?
STUDENT: Can you use the
Mitsunobu reaction?
PROFESSOR: Ah.
Mitsunobu inverts an alcohol.
If you have an alcohol, you can
go from right-handed to
left-handed.
But there's
no alcohol here.
What functionality is
handy? Rahul?
What's special about the
position of that H?
STUDENT: It's... I want to say
it's...
PROFESSOR: We want to
pull that hydrogen off and put
it back on the other side.
There are a zillion
hydrogens in here.
Ayesha?
STUDENT: Is it because it's next
to a carbonyl group?
PROFESSOR: Aha!
Enol, enolate.
OK.
So we want to go to that,
and you do it with base.
It's an enolate, and the trans
isomer is more stable, so it
goes all over there
via the enolate.
And now we're going to make
the ketones into alcohols.
Can you think of a reagent
that could do that?
This is review.
What kind of reagent
is necessary?
STUDENT: Reducing agent.
PROFESSOR: A
reducing agent.
Something that will add hydride
to the carbonyl.
Any ideas?
STUDENT: Hydrogen peroxide?
PROFESSOR:
Hydrogen peroxide.
Good idea, everyone?
STUDENT: No.
PROFESSOR: Why?
It's an oxidizing agent,
not a reducing agent.
Lithium aluminum hydride does
the trick, so you do that.
Now, what they want to do is
get from this diol now over
here to a ketone and
an unsaturation.
You already have an
unsaturation here.
So let's think about
how we do that.
The oxidation levels turn
out to be the same.
So you just use acid to
eliminate...acid in water, so
you can protonate and
get that cation.
But why get that cation?
Why not protonate here and get
the cation on the bottom, or
protonate here, and
lose methanol, and
get the cation there?
Well, the cation here is no
good, because it's a sigma--
it's in the sigma system.
It's not conjugated with
the double bond.
This one is allylic, but that
would be allylic too.
But if you make that one,
then the resonance
structure is here.
There's the vacant orbital, the
low LUMO is here and here,
And it's adjacent to the
unshared pair on oxygen.
So that's the one
you want to do.
So it takes off the one they
want to take off, at the top,
you get that.
Now you do an allylic
rearrangement of OH.
Or you complete the allylic
arrangement.
You took it off here, and
you put it on here.
Now, what functional group
do you have now,
when you have OH an OR
on the same carbon? Ruoyi?
STUDENT: Hemiketal.
PROFESSOR: What does it
do, what does a hemiketal do?
Loses alcohol.
Right?
So the hemiacetal here, treat it
with acid, protonate, lose
that, and you've got
the ketone now.
Right?
So we've got it to here.
But we need to get this OH off
to get down to what he wants
to build this over here.
So he treats it with
acetic anhydride.
What does an alcohol do with
the acetic anhyride?
The O attacks the carbonyl,
acetate leaves.
It's a substitution reaction
at an acyl carbon.
So you put acetate on here.
And now to get from here to
here, we have to change an O
on the ring into an
H on the ring.
What kind of reagent
do we need?
STUDENT: Reducing.
PROFESSOR: We need a
reducing agent, right?
So like a metal.
So we use the zinc. So zinc
comes in, gives electrons.
The acetate leaves.
So we generate this anion and
that double bond and enolate.
But of course, this is a
resonance structure of it, and
you put a proton on the
anion down there.
So he's got to that.
So now we're ready for
the next step.
And the next step is to build
ring B, and also, to protect
the double bond here so it won't
react when other double
bonds react.
And this thing here on B,
building this thing on B, will
be a handle to construct ring
A. And that double bond here
gives you access to that place,
which is, remember,
where we need to put a
ketone, which is sort
of off in left field.
OK.
So the first thing is to build
ring B. Did you ever see a
thing like that, where from
the ketone here we build a
whole six-membered
ring down here?
We saw it two lectures ago.
STUDENT: The Robinson
annulation.
PROFESSOR: The
Robinson annulation.
So what we need is ethyl vinyl
ketone, not methyl vinyl
ketone, but ethyl, in order
to get this extra
methyl group in here.
So this thing, which normally
would be methyl vinyl ketone,
is now ethyl vinyl ketone,
so we'll have that
methyl group on here.
OK.
So ethyl vinyl ketone generates
the enolate, does a
conjugate addition,
or sometimes
called a Michael addition.
Make that enolate anion,
protonate it, and now make the
other enolate anion and have it
attack the carbonyl to make
the beginning of that
double bond.
What would you call that
kind of reaction?
If you make this enolate react
with this, and end up with an
alpha, beta unsaturated ketone?
So you have a ketone attack
another ketone to give an
alpha-beta unsaturated ketone.
Remember what you call that?
Aldol.
You still have a week,
don't panic.
So we're going to do an
aldol reaction, and
then get over here.
Now, what we do there, in order
to make this protecting
group, is treat with
osmium tetroxyde.
We know that that
makes a diol.
We talked about that when
we were talking
about paracyclic reactions.
OK, so you can get the diol.
Then you make the diol into
this carbon with two more
methyls on it.
What kind of functional
group is this?
Two ORs on the same carbon.
That's a full acetal, right?
And you make it by reacting a
ketone acetone with a diol.
So we're going to get this
ketal, or acetal.
OK.
Now we need to go across
from here to here.
And what we're doing is removing
this double bond.
So that's done with catalytic
hydrogenation.
And notice, that's why
we had to protect
this double bond here.
Because it would have
been destroyed.
And if it was destroyed, then
you'd have no functionality
out here in order to change
the six ring into
five-membered ring and put
the other stuff on.
So you had to first
protect this, then
get rid of this one.
So now he's got this compound.
And now we're going to knock
ring D off while we work on
ring A so the whole slide
won't fill up.
So we'll just take that thing
up there and work on ring A.
Now, what kind of reaction might
make ring A an alpha
beta unsaturated ketone here?
Any reactions that give alpha,
beta unsaturated ketones?
STUDENT: Robinson?
PROFESSOR: Aldol
reactions.
So that's what we're going to be
looking for, but there are
some problems, as you'll see.
So we're going to do that.
We're going to get this, and
then an aldol reaction on that
will make this, and we can get
this by adding the anion here
conjugate to an alpha, beta
unsaturated ketone here.
What do we call it? What do you
call that kind of reaction?
STUDENT: Robinson annulation.
PROFESSOR: The whole
thing, to start from
here and build this ring. Build
a ring? You said it before.
STUDENT: Robinson annulation
PROFESSOR: Robinson
annulation,
we're going to do again.
So that would be ready
for the aldol.
And now this double bond here
is even closer to where we
needed in order to
make that ketone.
OK.
Now how do you do that?
Now there's a problem.
You have to make the enolate to
do the Robinson annulation.
But this is where you form
the enolate, down there.
You could remove one of these
hydrogens and make an enolate,
or you could remove one of those
hydrogens and make an
anion there, which would be
allylic with an anion there,
which is an enolate.
So this one is called a
vinylogous enolate.
It's got an extra double bond
in between, but still, it
would behave as an enolate.
But the problem is that this
one is more reactive.
You want to make the enolate
here, which you can do by
removing one of those purple
H's, and then having the anion
be there as a resonance
structure.
That's fine.
Except that these are the ones
that get pulled off easier.
So what do you do?
You go ahead, pull these off.
Tie them up somehow with
something else.
Then get the other one, and then
come back and take off
what you had put on there.
Use a protecting group.
And notice, incidentally, that
there's another H here that
could also be pulled off that
would have a resonance
structure with the anion here.
So there are lots of
possibilities.
You want to get that anion,
which is like that anion.
So first you have to
protect the more
reactive alpha position.
And they do that by--
that's just abbreviating
what's above.
Makes the enolate, attack that
carbonyl, which has a leaving
group on it, so the OCH3
will leave, and
generate this diketone.
That's like a Claisen reaction
that we talked about last
time, where an enolate
attacks an ester,
and the alcohol leaves.
And then that gets attacked
by an amine to give this.
And that dehydrates.
It's like making an alpha,
beta-unsaturated ketone,
except it has this nitrogen
on it now.
Which helps out.
The unshared pair on
the nitrogen is
stabilized by this.
You can draw resonance
structures that put charge on
the oxygen.
OK.
So this is like an aldol, an
alpha, beta-unsaturated ketone.
And also notice it's
an enamine.
So that's tied up the
downstairs part.
And now you can proceed with
making the anion you want,
which is going to add to
there, and hopefully by
Robinson methyl vinyl
ketone, or--
pardon me.
Yeah, methyl vinyl
ketone this time.
Because the first time, we had
to put the CH3 in there, when
we used this enolate
over here.
Now we don't need a CH3 here,
so we don't need it.
We can use methyl.
Except it doesn't work.
The reaction doesn't work.
So you have to do something
a little more roundabout.
So that doesn't work.
But if you can't add it to
methyl vinyl ketone, you can
add it to the double
bond here.
Do a conjugate addition
to this sort of like a
ketone, to that nitrile.
So the enolate adds to this
carbon, generate the anion
next to the nitrile.Then
protonate it, and you've got
that.
Conjugate addition again.
But the problem is, the
CH3 here could be
either up or down.
You could have added to either
face of that anion.
So here's what they said in
the paper about that.
"The protected ketone
was condensed with
acrylonitrile"--
that's that compound with
cyanide up at the top--
"in the presence of aqueous
Triton B in
t-butanol-benzine, solvent,
and the product on basic
hydrolysis yielded [this long
name thing], as a mixture
of two isomers."
That's the problem.
That's a mixture
of two isomers.
And that's just lore, whether
you're going to get
something like that.
And sometimes you just have to
suck it up, because there's no
hydrogen you can pull off
here to make it come
on the other side.
That's just the way it is.
So you've got to throw away a
certain amount of your stuff.
OK, so that's tough.
Right?
So then they used a strong base
and water, which removed
this protecting group.
Made it back into
the CH2 here.
And at the same time, it was
strong enough that it
hydrolyzed the nitrile to make
a carboxylic acid there
So now, treat that with acid,
protonate there. Then
protonate here, making
that cation.
But that can attack the carbonyl
to get that, which
can then lose a proton,
so you've got a
six-membered ring.
So have we made it?
Not quite.
We got the wrong element there,
oxygen instead of
carbon at the bottom.
So we need another carbon
in the system.
So protonate there, cation,
eliminate, we've got that
double bond.
OK.
But now we need to convert that
into ring A. We need to
put that extra blue methyl
group on there.
So the way to do it is to
use methyl Grignard.
So the methyl minus adds to the
carbonyl, and that is a
leaving group.
And that's an enolate, so
it becomes a ketone.
And we've got this thing here.
So we're getting closer now.
You do an aldol and
you have ring A.
So this is a typical
thing that happens.
It looked like a Robinson
annulation might go directly
there, but it didn't work,
so they do a work-around.
So now A is all set, and now
we need to work on ring D.
Which is, remember, a
six-membered ring, and it
needs to be a five-membered
ring.
So we'll put it up
in the corner and
start working on that.
So the first thing--what they're
going to go for is to
make it a five-membered ring
that has an ester group coming
off, so you have that
carbonyl groups that
we're going to want.
The first thing they do is treat
it with acid and water.
What do they do that for?
PROFESSOR: What's
that going to
do with that compound? Ayesha?
STUDENT: It's going to remove
the acetal and give the diol.
PROFESSOR: Right.
Now you can get rid of
the protecting group.
You want to be able to work on
that double bond now, so you
take the protecting group off
that you had on there when you
were doing the catalytic
hydrogenation.
And now we've got the diol.
And now treat it with
periodic acid.
You remember what that does?
STUDENT: Oxidizes.
J.MICHAEL MCBRIDE: It oxidizes a
diol to cleave the carbon-carbon
bond in between and make two
carbonyl groups.
So at first it adds, and then
that's just an intermediate, a
transient intermediate.
It comes apart to give
two aldehydes.
And now, how are you going
to make a
five-membered ring?
STUDENT: Decarboxylation.
PROFESSOR: You can make
an enolate here, attack
that carbonyl, or
make an enolate
here, attack this carbonyl.
Those are going to give
different products.
What you need to do is to have
this enolate attack this
carbonyl if you want to make
that compound, rather than
have this enolate react with
that one, and get the
carboxylic acid down here.
It turns out that base with
aldol could be either that way
or that way, and luck made it
go the right way this time.
Robinson annulation didn't
work before, but this one
worked the right way.
And then we've got
an aldehyde.
We need the carboxylic acid.
So you use dichromate oxidation,
which we talked
about, to oxidize an alcohol.
And of course, you don't stop
at the aldehyde, you
go on to the acid.
But you need the ester.
So now they're going
to make the ester.
You could do Fischer
esterification, but that's an
equilibrium, and this stuff
is becoming very precious,
because of all the work
that you put into it.
So you want to do this in the
highest possible yield.
So they use diazomethane,
remember, which is the way of
doing it really to change the
acid into methyl ester in
really high yield.
So that's a dangerous compound
to work with.
It's much more expensive and
cumbersome than doing a
Fischer esterification.
But it gives a really
high yield, so
that's what they did.
So now they had the
ketone here.
And now they made
into an alcohol.
Now, this looks nuts, right?
they already had the
ketone there, which
is what they want.
And the double bond here,
they've got it.
Why do they backtrack?
They backtracked because it was
already known from 1918--
so they used borohydride this
time to reduce the ketone to
an alcohol.
If they'd used lithium aluminum
hydride, it would
have reduced the ester to an
alcohol, and they didn't want
to do that.
So you have to choose the
reagents carefully when
there's possible competition
like that.
Now, it was 1909 it was found
out that this alcohol could be
separated, the two enantiomers,
easily.
That was already known 50
years before, right?
So they backtracked in order--
see, all this stuff they've
been doing started with
achiral material.
So they've got both right and
left-handed stuff there, and
they want only the one
enantiomer, ultimately.
And someplace, they're going
to have to separate it, and
this is where they do
the separation.
Because it turns out, if you put
this in together with this
digitonin stuff, which itself,
notice, has a six, six, six,
five steroid inside it--
this complicated
sapogenin, as it's called.
Then those things come
together, and what
precipitates is just one hand.
The other one stays
in solution.
So this was obviously lore.
But anyhow, they got that.
And now, having made this, it
turned out that previous
studies of cortisone had shown
that if you had this, you
could make this from it.
So this in this is called
a total synthesis.
But in fact, it's
a formal total
synthesis, or a relay synthesis.
Because by the time they got
here, they had very little
material, so they couldn't
do a bunch more steps.
But it was known that those
steps could be done, because
people had already done them.
So they could, then, start with
material which had been
made from cortisone or
some other sterol and
then carry it through.
But there was no point in doing
it, because people had
already done those reactions.
So this is the paper.
This is the whole paper that
described the total synthesis
of cortisone.
Woodward was not a man
of many words.
Right?
There had actually been a
previous paper of about two
pages about making the precursor
that we showed.
So he then had this.
He reduced this double bond.
But notice, it did reduce this
one and this one, but didn't
reduce this one.
So again, this is testing the
various methods you're using
to make sure what's going
to react and what isn't.
Why didn't they want to get
rid of that double bond?
Because that's the one that's
going to give them the handle
to get that ketone in up
there, which is a very
difficult position.
And then they could do sodium
borohydride that made the
alcohol that we showed
you before.
But notice that the borohydride
didn't attack here.
It only attacked down here.
Then they made the acetate
from that alcohol.
And now they've got to convert
this to cortisone.
At this point, our synthetic
work intersects the lines
previously laid down in the
extensive prior investigations
by many groups.
So he goes through some
of these groups.
"Heymann and Fieser"--
that's the guy that wrote
this story, right--
"have recently converted the
acetoxy-ester (III) into [this
compound] V." So here's the
reference to that.
It was worked in 1951.
So what they did was to--
let's see, whoa, whoa, whoa, we
have a lot of stuff here--
reaction four, oh, reference
four, reference five, then
reference six puts that thing
on up there, and then
reference seven puts the
alcohol in or whatever.
And finally the double bond
by Mattox and Kendall.
Kendall, remember, is the guy
that got the Nobel Prize, the
chemist at the Mayo Institute.
So that did it.
They had it.
They'd solve the intellectual
artistic problem of how you
can start with simple,
available
compounds and make cortisone.
But what was the yield?
Think a minute about yield.
Suppose you do 39 steps, and
each step has an 80% yield,
which isn't so bad, as
you've found in lab.
Right?
Then the overall yield is 0.01%
if you take 0.8 to the
39th power.
But there's a different
way to go about it,
what's called a convergence
synthesis, where
you make several big pieces,
and then link the pieces
together, so the distance in
number of steps from any one
starting material to the product
is smaller than having
all 39 in a row.
So you could start with
something that does nine
steps, say, that makes A.
Another nine step sequence
makes B. Another makes C, and
another makes D. And now you
put A and B together, and C and
D together, to make E and F,
and then you put
them together.
And now the distance is only
nine steps plus two steps for
any given starting material,
and you get a 9% yield.
So convergent synthesis
has real advantages.
Now, how about a practical
cortisone synthesis that could
make something that people
could afford to use?
Well, there's cortisone.
Remember, that's what the
Nobel laureate said.
There are two things
you can do.
Either do a total synthesis,
or get a better starting
material than was
then available.
So choose an appropriate,
readily
available starting material.
OK.
Desoxycholic acid, a bile acid
that you can get from
slaughterhouses, or get the
glands from which to make it
from slaughterhouses.
It comes from ox bile.
So in 1946, '49, Merck made a
kilogram of cortisone from 600
kilograms of that bile acid
which came from an enormous
amount of stuff from
the slaughterhouse.
But notice why that was a
good starting material.
It has all the rings in place
of the right size,
and it's properly methylated.
So it's got the skeleton,
the carbon skeleton.
It's got all those things in
the right stereochemistry.
It's got, here, functional
groups at or near at least
some of the proper positions.
You're going to have to fiddle
around out here somehow.
But how are you going
to do that?
Well, you could imagine, they
were able to go in twelve
steps to that.
And we're not going to go
through what those next 20
steps are that allow you
to get the red thing.
But you could imagine things
like, do a bromination at a
tertiary position.
Maybe you could do that.
Then eliminate HBr, maybe.
It could go the wrong way.
Then maybe you could cleave the
double bond and make the
ketone, then maybe you could do
alpha-bromination adjacent
to the ketone, and then make
alcohols from that.
Something like that.
You can imagine.
That's not what was done.
That wouldn't be twenty steps.
It didn't work that way.
But you can imagine ways that
you could get at it.
So they did it in 20 steps.
So then they got cortisone.
And they could sell it in 1949
for $200 a gram, having made
it by a 32 step sequence.
But there's another compound
called diosgenin.
And diosgenin also has the right
set of rings and the
right stereochemistry, and
functionality in a good place.
And it's abundant in
a Mexican yam.
And Russell Marker, who was an
organic chemist at Penn State
University, went exploring.
He sort of quit and went down to
Mexico and looked around to
see if he could find
natural things that
contained a lot of this.
And the roots of this yam--
some of them are 20 or 50
kilograms, and a fair
percentage of it
is this stuff.
So he was able to find a
good source of this.
And it could be converted in
five steps into progesterone,
a female hormone.
And so in 1943, he got ten tons
of that yam and from it,
made three kilograms of
progesterone, which was then
worth a quarter million
dollars,
which is-- in 1943, which
is like, I don't
know, $5 million now.
He had the world's supply
of progesterone,
which is a pregnancy hormone.
And so it was selling in 1955
for 48 a gram, instead of
this $200/gram stuff.
But there's a problem if you
want to get cortisone this
way, because there's no foothold
to get at that
position, rather than that one
or that one or that one or
that one or that one or
that one or that one.
How are you going to
put the ketone in?
And this is where it was found,
actually, by this guy
here, or by his research
group.
Frederick Heyl, who was an
undergraduate and graduate
student here, was the director
of research at Upjohn.
And at Upjohn research in
Kalamazoo, they found out that
they had some of this-- a mold
started growing on a dish that
was in a windowsill.
And when you put it
on here, it put a
ketone in that position.
Pardon me.
Put the alcohol in
that position.
But then once you've got the
alcohol here, you're home
free, right?
OK.
So Woodward had done the total
synthesis of cortisone, and he
did a lot of total syntheses.
Like the strychnine
synthesis here.
I thank Professor Saunders,
who took these pictures.
He was still a graduate student
at this time in 1954
when strychnine was
synthesized.
And the interesting thing
about Woodward--
there was real cult of
personality, still is, among
older people.
Because young people don't
know who he was anymore.
Because he was such an artist. I
mean, designing these things
is an art, but you have to
really know a lot to
see the art in it.
And his Nobel citation actually,
said "for his
outstanding achievements in the
art of organic synthesis."
I don't think there's never been
another Nobel citation
that said art in it.
So he made a lot of
these things.
Here was strychnine, a very
challenging thing.
And so when they got it done,
they drew it very carefully on
the blackboard.
And the postdocs who
had worked on it--
Ollis was a faculty member
from the University of
Bristol, in England.
Hunger was a German.
Daeniker and Schenker were
from Switzerland.
And Cava was an American
who went to be a
professor at Penn.
But you'll notice, when Woodward
got the Nobel prize,
his colleagues wrote this
in Science magazine.
"Woodward's style is polished,
showing an insight and sense
of proportion that afford him
strong convictions and a
well-developed dramatic
sense."
So you can see, just the way
he's lighting his cigarette
there looks sort of
dramatic to me.
And look at his signature!
He always signed minuscule
signatures.
R. B. Woodward.
And they also put a check mark
on it when they finished the
synthesis, and down in the
bottom wrote, "fecunt."
So you know Latin.
I talked to Victor Bers in
the classics department.
That's not a proper
Latin word.
But fecerunt means,
they made it.
Right?
So that's what-- they almost
got it right, evidently,
writing that on the
blackboard.
But one of the hallmarks of
Woodward's style was that he
always wore the same color
blue suit and blue tie.
So that's a Woodward blue tie.
And in fact, students, one
Halloween, painted his parking
place that light blue.
And I know where they got the
paint, because I got it.
OK.
So then in 1973, they did this
real pinnacle of synthesis.
They synthesized vitamin B12.
You can't imagine all
the problems that
were faced by this.
And it was a collaborative
work between Woodward and
Eschenmoser's laboratory at
the ETH in Zurich, in
Switzerland.
And in connection with this
work is where Woodward
discovered stereochemical
control by orbital symmetry.
Those are called the
Woodward-Hoffmann rules.
You know, conrotation,
disrotation.
And it was while working on this
that he discovered that.
They had 100 coworkers
at these two
labs, working on this.
All of them very,
very talented.
Including this guy, Yoshito
Kishi, who was a faculty
member from Nagoya University
who had come to work on this
project with Woodward.
And this is what Woodward wrote
about him when, in Pure
and Applied Chemistry in 1971,
he wrote about working on the
B12 synthesis.
"The first preparation of
corrigenolide afforded
striking testimony of the
experimental skill of its
discoverer, Dr. Yoshito Kishi.
All the operations had to
be conducted with every
conceivable precaution in
respect to purity of reagents,
exclusion of oxygen and
moisture, and with the
greatest possible speed."
So he was a real wizard
in the laboratory.
And he then joined the Harvard
faculty after that, and then
succeeded Woodward as professor
at Harvard after
Woodward's untimely death.
And we've seen his
name before.
Not for this.
He ultimately synthesized
palytoxin, this compound,
which has C-123, H-213, NO-53.
It's got 42 functional groups
which were protected in eight
different ways.
So you could remove
some of them, put
others on, and so on.
It has 62 stereogenic centers.
It has seven double bonds that
could be either E or Z, so
there are 10 to the 20th
stereoisomers possible.
And it was done convergently.
So they made eight different
pieces and then put those
pieces together.
So you'd get no yield at all
if you did this in a
sequential synthesis, right?
But they actually made it.
And it was not-- although that
was just a tour de force, it's
related to practical stuff.
Because we talked last fall
about this Eisai drug, which
has a lot of similarity
to that.
And the week after we spoke
about it in class, the FDA
approved it for treating
metastatic breast cancer.
Remember we talked about
whether that was
pending at the time.
And you'll notice that
the leader of
this group was Kishi.
So he had cut his teeth on
palytoxin for synthesizing
things like this, so that this
drug can now be made
synthetically, practically, and
sold as a drug that way.
It's just incredible.
So organic synthesis has come
a long way from urea.
Remember what Woehler wrote to
Berzelius in 1828 about the
experiment when he reacted
"cyanic acid with ammonia and
a crystalline substance appears
which is inert,
behaving neither like cyanate
nor like ammonia."
So that's the story.
But first, that a little bit
of thanks and credit.
First to George Maxfield,
who was my high
school chemistry teacher.
I remember his doing--
we'd be working on something,
and he wouldn't be doing
anything at all.
He'd go like this.
And the other thing he did was
he said, "You make something,
you put it in a bottle and sell
it to your neighbor." So
I'm quoting him.
And there's Theodore Roosevelt
Williams, who was my first
college professor at the College
of Worcester.
And then Fieser we talked
about, and Bartlett, and
Conant was his boss, who had two
PhD advisors, a physical
chemist, T.W. Richards, who got
the Nobel Prize, and an
organic chemist, E. P. Kohler,
who was very--
these three pictures were
all taken at Yale.
That was when Sterling
was dedicated.
This was at a meeting in 1931
when Bartlett was just 24 years
old. But Kohler never went
to meetings.
He never left Harvard.
People would come there to talk
to him, but he wasn't
interested in that.
He just taught all the time.
And Kohler's the one that
finally resolved aline.
Remember, we talked about that
van 't Hoff had predicted it.
But Kohler's the one
that made it.
So Kohler was a student
of Remson, who
was at Johns Hopkins.
And Richards studied
with Ostwald.
Remember, the guy that didn't
believe in atoms?
And then the next generation
back was Fittig, who
discovered the pinacol
reaction.
And the one person I couldn't
find a picture of was Carl
Schmidt, who was at
Riga in Latvia.
But he was described by Ostwald
as a "tall, thin man
with a small head, a strong
nose, ice gray hair, and a
thin beard." And a very
nice person, right?
And Schimdt had worked both
with Liebig and Woehler.
He was first a student
of Woehler, who
recommended him to Liebig.
Fittig had worked
with Woehler.
So we're back to those guys.
And then to Gay-Lussac
and Berzelius.
And then to Bertole, who was a
colleague of Lavoisier, and
wrote how to name compounds.
But there are some other heroes
to whom we should pay
homage, even if they weren't
our ancestors.
You know who this is?
STUDENT: Moses Gomberg
PROFESSOR: Right.
Who's this?
Emil Fischer.
The last lecture.
Koerner.
The other guy who did a real
proof in the 19th century.
James Clark Maxwell.
Remember him?
Couper.
The tetravalence of carbon.
Lavoisier.
And Robert Hooke.
There's no known picture of
Hooke, because Newton probably
destroyed it.
I think that's true!
But this is a picture
of somebody
using Hooke's apparatus.
And Hooke was a hunchback,
and he drew that picture.
And I like to think that might
be a self-portrait, although I
sort of doubt it.
But Hooke was certainly
a great guy.
And then of course we have a lot
of people we have to pay
homage to at Yale, too.
Like Silliman, with his T-shirts
that says, "How do
you know?"
Or a giant.
Who's this?
STUDENT: Gibbs
PROFESSOR: Gibbs.
And Onsager.
Those two--
Gibbs was arguably the smartest
guy in the 19th
century, or certainly among
the top half dozen or so.
And Onsager was the same
in this century.
And I actually had Onsager
as a colleague.
We overlapped for a few years.
I mean, he's-- like, Feynman
was in awe of Onsager.
And when Onsager got the Nobel
Prize, when they called to
inform him, he asked, "What
for?" Because he had done so
many things that could have
gotten the Nobel Prize.
And then, you know this is?
Chupka.
These are the colleagues
I've enjoyed having
around for a while.
And he came in and told people
how he determined the heat of
vaporization of carbon.
And that one, you know.
Wiberg.
And here's Professors Ziegler.
These are people who gave
lectures in the course, right?
And of course, you
know who's next.
Not a faculty member, but a
graduate student from Yale.
And then someone who's
almost from Yale.
Leslie Leiserowitz
who spoke to you
last semester.
He's from Israel, but he comes
so often to visit that we'll
call him an honorary Yalie.
And then these people
we quoted.
Remember, he's the guy
that originated "How
do you know" hourly?
And she's the one that
does it now.
And this is my wife, and
that's John's wife.
And here's-- this was night
before last over across the
street here, at a meeting of
the Connecticut Science
Teachers Association,
when this plaque was
awarded to my wife.
And she's sitting back here.
And next to her is the Biology
professor from Bowdoin whom
I've quoted.
And she's sitting
back there, too.
And then these are the kids--
it's the next generation,
right?
And they're here with
Caroline Doty.
You know who Caroline Doty is,
a basketball player at UConn.
So we'd gone to a UConn game.
So I don't know what they're
going to do.
They might be scientists.
They might be basketball
players.
They might be lawyers,
doctors.
But you guys are going
to be that, too.
And you're going to be their
teachers, or their healers, or
Lord forbid, defend them in
court, or something like that.
OK.
So there you are.
So I want to thank
all the students.
Not only you guys,
but many years.
So thanks.
We'll have a review on
Monday in room 110.
There's going to be
a symposium here.
So at class time on Monday,
we'll have a
review down the hall.
And good luck on the final,
and that's it.
Thank you.